Now this occurrence is extending
over a protracted period of time.
And as the elder gods are threatened,
they're also breeding and
mating and producing new forms,
and they produce a great,
great grandson whose name is Marta.
Now,
Marta has a lot of very
interesting attributes.
The attributes are described in the
Enuma Elish in the following manner.
So this is what Mark's father sees
when his wife Damn Kina gives birth to
Marduk.
So when he,
who's Marnix father saw his son,
he rejoiced,
he beamed,
his heart was filled with joy.
He distinguished him and conferred
upon him double equality with the gods.
Okay,
so that's the first indication that
whatever Martech represents is something
that's elevated beyond the normal
status of a primordial density,
so that he was highly
exalted and surpassed them in
everything artfully arranged
beyond comprehension,
where his members not fit
for human understanding,
hard to look upon for his eyes,
forward his ears when his lips move,
fire blazed forth.
Each of his four years grew large and
likewise his eyes to see everything he was
exalted among God's
surpassing was his form.
His members were gigantic.
He was surpassing in height.
Mary Youtube,
Mary you to one of his names,
son of the son,
God the son,
God of the Gods.
Okay.
Complex bit of poetry.
It says a bunch of things.
It says,
well,
whatever Martech is is
the offspring of the gods.
Whatever Marta is is characterized
by heightened awareness,
right?
Because he has four years and
four eyes and they're large.
Whatever Martech is characterized by as
the status that surpasses that of his
father's.
Whatever he's characterized by is
associated with the power of speech,
real power.
Because when he speaks fire spurts,
fourth mark is also huge.
But more importantly,
he's associated in this
particular poem with the Sun.
Why is that?
Well,
the sun dominates consciousness,
right?
Because we're conscious during the day.
Most of our brain is visual cortex.
So we're visual creatures.
So when the sun rises
is when the day begins.
So martech is also
associated with whatever.
Danny dominates the day,
and that's the daddy of consciousness.
And there's more to the story of the Sun,
right?
Because the sun is also something
that rises and sets repeatedly.
And that means that the daddy
that dominates consciousness
is characterized by a
cyclical nature.
That's a son.
Myth.
Sunrises in the morning,
renewed as a consequence of fighting a
terrible battle in the night with the
enemies of everything that's
associated with consciousness.
A Classic Solar Myth.
So absolute entire Matt give
rise to the world of the gods,
the activity of the world of Gods
reawakens tie amat she decides to destroy
everything,
but at that moment,
the gods give birth to Marduk.
Now,
that's a typical Motif,
which is that the hero's always
born at the time of maximal crisis.
And the reason for that is,
in part,
it's simple.
Look,
if your culture is dealing well with
the forces of the unknown so that
everything is static,
static,
but productive,
so that problems themselves don't arise,
there's no reason for the hero,
right?
There's no reason to confront the unknown.
It's only when crisis backends that
the birth of the hero is necessary.
Marduk constitutes the birth of the hero.